- Hello, I'm Tan France
and this is Dressing Funny.
Each episode I'm dressing
some of the funniest people on the planet.
Let me get you a napkin.
- I don't love this person.
- What?
- Will we laugh a lot?
(laughs)
Yes!
Will someone get pegged?
- This is perfect.
- Yeah
- There we go.
- Almost.
Will I teach women about
vaginal rejuvenation.
- I'm depressed, I have
vaginal rejuvenation,
I'm an alcoholic.
- Yes.
Will I lay with another man?
- I'd never wear a
condom, I'm a gentleman.
- Yes.
Will I marry this woman?
- I do.
- I don't.
No.
Abso-fucking-lutely not.
Either way, you'll see
your favorite comedians
like you've never seen them before.
- Please just live in my house.
- Righteo!
I'm sure I get on.
- He looks so hot I'm sure
I'm gonna try to fuck him
in the Writer's Room.
- Delightful.
- Just watch.
(doorbell rings)
(techno music)